c'est une friche industrielle qui
s'étend sur 15 hectares à saint pierre
des corps les anciens magasins généraux
de la sncf se cherche un avenir depuis
2006 date de leur fermeture
le 29 juin prochain lors du conseil
municipal de la commune il sera encore
question de ce site laissé à l'abandon
le maire souhaiterait le vendre un
groupe privé pour qu'il soit réhabilité
un collectif de citoyens envisage d'en
faire un lieu alternatif
le point avec samuel colin 220 m de long
sur 50 de large
bienvenue dans ce qui est parfois
appelée la cathédrale un bâtiment de 28
mille mètres carrés baigné de lumière
grâce à ses verrières typique de
l'époque industrielle leur conception
originale et en trois rangées en font un
vestige unique en france
il a remplacé les vitrages restaurer les
menuiseries gérer désenfumage et voilà
assuré toutes les contraintes liées
besoins d'accueil du public faire
revivre ce lieu à l'abandon depuis 2006
ils seraient une centaine à lui avoir en
quelques semaines à peine imaginer un
tout autre avenir
une salle de spectacle des studios de
répétition des espaces de coworking des
bureaux mais aussi un centre commercial
et un garage liées à l'économie sociale
et solidaire encore à l'étude
les financements devraient être soutenus
par des instances publiques mais
pourrait aussi se trouver en tant que
copropriétaire
on a plein de modèles comme ça qui nous
permet de dire oui c'est possible et
notamment le bateau ivre qui en fait
reviendrait à faire la même chose en dix
fois plus grand l'idée pour eux présenté
un projet parallèle à celui de la mairie
de saint pierre des corps
propriétaire des 5 6 hectares du site
celle ci aimerait le vendre car elle n'a
plus les moyens d'entretenir le bâtiment
et son étanchéité et encore moins ceux
d'une rénovation au moins 50 millions
d'euros à mettre sur la table selon le
maire nous vendrions le bâtiment et nous
avons travaillé de façon à ce que ceux
qui investiront ce bâtiment plus à
portée de l'emploi à
saint-pierre-des-corps parle de pas loin
de 1000 emplois sans dépenser un seul
deniers publics
l'entreprise vinci serait intéressé pour
créer un pôle de recherche et
développement au rayonnement européen
nous n'en serons pas plus pour l'instant
si ce n'est qu'un accès au public doit
être maintenue grâce à un lieu de
restauration
le collectif le réveil du magasin
général doit faire sa présentation le 31
mai à la mairie en commission
d'urbanisme
le choix du projet retenu sera ensuite
voté au conseil municipal à la fin du
mois de juin